il descend il
attaque mais un bruit de de malade
mental une fumée comme si ça sortait
d'une cheminé comme ça et il continue et
d'un coup dans l'orillette j'entends
patrouille de flic patrouille je dirais
chacun son poste je le dis pas à l'autre
je dis chacun son poste restons
tranquille restons tranquille hop on là
je fais mine et puis je les revois les
flic ils arrivent au feu rouge comme ça
salut aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
David Desclos qui vient à cette
interview à la table c'est un ancien
cambrrioleur de banque qui était
spécialisé dans la neutralisation des
alarmes évidemment il a eu une vie hors
norme entre le fait de creuser des
tunnels de faire de la prison d'être en
cavale de travailler avec des personnes
du grand banditisme et il a la
générosité de venir nous raconter tout
on a tous eu un premier job dans la vie
souvent les comédiens ont été serveurs
avant ce genre de choses le tien c'est
c'est un peu hors du commun on peut dire
que tu as été bandit j'aime bien le mot
bandit au sens large du terme ça te
convient ou pas c'est c'est comme ça que
que les dé fin mon passé ok alors du
coup c'est c'est quoi ton premier
apprentissage ton premier fait d'arme
ton premier délit tu avvec quel âge ah
j'étais très jeune j'étais très jeune
mon premier délir vraiment je pour pas
me faire passer pour un mytho je dis
toujours 8 9 ans mais Ctait plus près
des 7 quoi sais c'est vol àage pour
manger quoi pour on était voilà c'est
pas une excuse on était très très pauvre
il y avait av une petite superérette
dans le bas du quartier voilà et
j'allais à la superette jeais dans la
super et j'étais très vraiment très très
jeune et je ramena à la maison pour pour
les le frère la sœur ma mère voilà mon
papa voilà c'est je jette pas la pierre
mais voilà a sombré très vite dans
l'alcool et tout donc c'est ça a été une
jeunesse assez particulière quoi c'était
elle disait quoi ta maman quand tu
ramenais de la nourriture vers 6 ans 6
ans et demi 7 ans un petit peu j'allais
frapper aux portes des voisins chinis du
lait du pain voilà j'allais chiner voilà
et donc j'en ai eu un petit peu marre
d'aller à la à la mangave quand on
appelit ça la mangave la mandicité et
donc j'ai été quand quand je revenais de
cette super ben je disais bah c'est les
voisins dans un premier temps elle y AC
du feu quoi donc ça veut dire déjà une
grande maturité parce que ça veut dire
qu' 7 ans on va dire tu avais déjà
conscience que bon faut pas faire ça
mais on a besoin de le faire mais je
vais pas me mettre en porte à fau et je
vais trouver une histoire crédible ouais
ça c'est je je voilà je j'ai toujours
très jeune voilà j'ai le verbe facile le
baratin puis je je me considère pas
comme quelqu'un de très intelligent non
plus parce que je par la suite après
j'ai repensé à des jeunes qui étaient
comme moi dans la vraie misère aussi
comme moi et qui ont été qu' qu' on pas
été volés moi je dis toujours que pour
rentrer dans le vol la délinquan ça
c'est c'est une bonne mayonnaise il faut
que tous les ingrédients soient réunis
et pour moi tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis c'estàdire
ben l'ambiance familiale déjà ensuite le
caractère les connaissances avec qui tu
traînes les jeunes et mon papa avait été
en prison quand il était jeune donc il
avait ce parcours une fois qu'il est
tombé dans l'alcool il ressassait avec
ses frères tout toute cette histoire
j'écoutis j'étais petit j'écoutis ça
fait un ingrédient en plus pour cette
bonne mayonnaise quoi c'est et donc je
suis parti dans tout ça et d'ailleurs tu
le dis dans ton livre à un moment donné
tu dis que pour toi le destin d'un
délinquant ça commence le jour de sa
naissance en fait pour moi voilà ouais
c'est c'est l'un des premiers voilà
c'est l'un des premiers éléments des sa
il y a un célèbre chanteur qui a chanté
une chanson être né quelque part tu vois
c'est moi elle me parle cette chanson
parce que c'est vrai que si vous vous
étiez né là où ils sont né où on est né
et que il y aur eu toute cette bonne
maillonnae pour vous aussi enfin tous
ces ingrédients et tout est-ce que vous
auriez pas fait par on sait on peut pas
savoir on peut pas jugeras tu as les
cartes que tu as en main et tu composes
avec avec tes qualités et tes défauts
toi tu as comme qualité tu parlais
d'intelligence je pense une forme
d'intelligence sociale V de comprendre
les autres savoir quoi dire savoir
comment passer entre guillemets ou c'est
j'ai j'ai appris tout ça sur le tard
dans dans la l'école de la rue quoi tout
jeune même quand ben je me suis fait
même pincer dans cette super j'arrive à
esquiver j'arrive tu tu fais bah tu tu
mets ton intelligence ton culot et ton
talent du mauvais côté de la barrière
très jeune c'est de la survie quoi c'est
c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer dans
le livre si j'essaie d'expliquer tout ça
apporter une au moins une explication à
ces personnes qui qui ne savent pas je
dis pas que c'est bien mais ça
s'explique exactement c'est la bonne
formule je dis pas que c'est bien mais
ça s'explique et je donne à mon humble
niveau une explication tu as raconté
aussi que tu avais fait un stage en
maçonnerie et tu t'étais rendu compte
que la vie rangée c'était facile
finalement assez précaire aussi avec un
petit fond d'exploitation quand même
derrière ce moment-là tu as 15 ans si je
dis pas de bêtises et donc tu te dis
donc alors soit je fais ma son je me
fais exploiter et je gagne rien soit
aussi j'ai de l'autre c'est un peu la
peste et le coléra quoi c'est ça vois
que bah en discutant et surtout j'ai ce
verbe facile encore une fois je parle
avec mes collègues je parle et de les
entendre se plaindre les entendre leur
vie de ce qu'ils ont je les respecte
énormément parce que j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir parlé avec eux et à quel point
ils en ont baver et de tenir et d'élever
leur leurs enfants de de tenir cette
famille tout ça le foyer et toi à ce
moment-là quand tu entends tout ça tu
penses quoi tu ressens quoi c'est est-ce
que tu dis c'est pas pour moi ou ou
est-ce que c'est un juste d'une manière
générale ça ça te fait quoi
intérieurement ben c'est là que je
rentre dans cette bêtise où je me dis ah
non je veux pas en baver autant quoi je
veux pas
je je me dis non non c'est pas pour moi
et et alors que je me trompe parce que
voilà c'est comme ça qu' en fait c'est
la vie c'est la vie pour fonder une
famille et tout ça et j'en dans cette
bêtise et et je me dis non et je pars du
mauvais côté de la barrière est-ce que
c'est à cette période là juste après la
maçonnerie qui intervient la la cité
alors je sais pas comment on dit des
cheitan la cité des cheéan ouais est-ce
que tu peux nous en parler et nous
donner un peu ton rôle làdedans on
déménage du quartier de la grâce de Dieu
je suis très jeune j'ai j'ai 9 ans on
arrive à la pirosée et on arrive dans au
43 alors le le 43 a toute une histoire
pour pour nous parce que c'est que mon
père venait du d'une cité d'urgence
s'appelle qui s'appelait le 43 à Camp
c'est une ancienne caserne de militaire
qui après la guerre ils ont mis tous les
Pau vous quand avait été détruit à 90 %.
et le 43 est devenu avec tonoville à
côté Tonneville ok parce que c'est en
forme de tonneau c'était vraiment tout
toute la misère de camp était là-bas 43
tonoville et mon père a grandandi
làdedans tonoville 43 et tout ça et le
43 était très connu alors le 43 AC
tonoville amène mon père en prison banne
pour enfants et tout ça et tout et quand
on déménage de la grâce de Dieu qu'on
arrive à la pireosé et on nous attribue
le bâtiment numéro 43 et ma mère dit à
mon
père tu as vu le numéro et mon père est
dit c'est qu'un numéro et ben non le 43
est devenu la la tour infernale et c'est
la bascule se fait là quoi ça va un
petit peu mieux à la maison mon papa est
toujours dans l'alcool grave mais ma
mère a réussi à
relever on a quand même une maison
propre un fr voilà le frigo ça va mieux
et tout on a du mal à payer les loyers
tout ça c'est c'est dur mais c'est mieux
qu'à la grâce de Dieu grâce à ma mère
c'est beaucoup mieux beaucoup mieux bon
je je stoppe l'école tout ça et j'ai ses
stages ENF dans différents métiers dans
Don la plomberie et bien à force de
discuter avec toutes ces personnes tout
je m'aperçois que c'est c'est des
métiers très durs qui vont et qui payent
pas quoi et et moi mon objectif mon but
depuis et quelques voilà un paquet de
temps là dans ma tête c'est sortir ma
famille de tout ça ok ma famille et mes
amis et je me dis c'est pas avec une
petite payille de misère que je vais y
arriver et donc je pars dans l'autre
sens le bandit la délinquence ensuite le
banditisme parce que je me dis bah il y
a que comme ça que je vais trouver
suffisamment assez de fond pour sortir
ma famille et mes amis parce que on est
une équipe on est ce gang tous ensemble
alors et et avec avec des règles sans
armes sans violence voilà mais je pars à
pleine là-dedans en faisant ce choix et
là la suite c'est infil est-ce que
est-ce que dans le fond le fait de de
bien préparer d'avoir des vraies valeurs
pas de violence pas n'importe quoi pas
n'importe comment le fait
d'avoir un vrai objectif aussi de se
dire aider à sortir la famille et les
amis est-ce que du coup tu penses pas
que dans le fond tu avais tu avais l'art
du travail bien fait c'est-à-dire que
c'était pas de la délinquence pour la
délinquence moi quand je t'entends bah
je me dis ok il fait un truc truc est
pas légal par contre le mec bosse quoi
et il veut du travail bien fait et je
pense au-delà que de on se fait pas
arrêter c'est juste déjà le plaisir de
se dire on a fait au mieux quoi C
c'était exactement ça et il y avait une
une ambigué il y avait vraiment un grand
écart entre deux choses c'est que d'un
côté on était comme ça le travail bien
fait minutieux tout calculé tout tout
propre et tout sans armes sans violence
tout nickel et d'un autre côté la vie
dans le quartier cette vie autour de ce
43 en bas des tour nous amener à
d'autres un parallèle complètement
différent où là il y avait beaucoup de
violence si on avait eu les téléphones
portables que les jeunes ont maintenant
et qu'on aurait filmé un un quart de de
ce qu'on a vécu les gens reviendraient
pas et diraient c'est c'est pas possible
d'ailleurs il y a il y a quelque chose
qui est très très fascinant il y avait
énormément de violence autour de toi
comme tu l'as expliqué là tout à l'heure
parfois à la maison souvent à
l'extérieur et toi tu as toujours refusé
de l'employé ouais tu tu tu sais tu sais
pourquoi ou ça a été genre une valeur
dure dès le départ en fait c'est en déjà
déjà quand quand quand je voyais mon
père très très très très jeune quand
j'étais là j'étais je voyais mon père et
je me disais je non je Seris je veux pas
c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais bu jamais
fumé jamais drogué et quand j'ai vu mon
père comme ça et je disais pareil pour
la violence je voulais pas voilà on
préfère abandonner un coup que de faire
de la violence c'était
vraiment très important pour moi c'était
en moi quoi ça je je ne l'inventais pas
c'était en moi les personne qui ne
pensaient pas comme nous et ben ils
formaient leur gang à part et il faisit
ils ont fait ils ont grandi avec nous
mais ils ont fait des choses très
violentes et tout et donc c'était ça à à
quel âge tu fais ton premier séjour en
prison mon premier séjour en prison je
le fais à 18 ans j'aurais dû y aller
avant mais grâce à ma mère grâce au juge
pour mineur le juge pour mineur fait
fait un gros travail parce qu'il avait
mis les plus anciens nos générations
dessus les avaient mis tous en prison OK
et il s'était rendu compte que c'était
pas la solution bah c'était que pire
quoi il sortaiit c'était l'école du
crime la prison il sortait encore pire
et et çaavait çaavait rien çaavait rien
eu de bon et donc pour nous il a essayé
de faire autrement il a essayé mais on
était tellement parti tellement donc il
a essayé de me placer il m'a placé chez
maente à Paris il m'a placé dans des
foyers dans des truc il est et jusqu'à
ce que je fasse mon devancement d'appel
à 17 ans j'ai fait mon devancement
d'appel pour l'armée parce que là je
devais y aller en prison et je dis non
non j'ai eu cette idée de faire le
devance appelle je pas à l'armée je vais
faire carrière militaire qu'est-ce que
c'est des cl je dis ah si il m'a dit bon
certes essayons si dans quelques mois
vous êtes vraiment à l'armée je vous
mettrai du surcil donc j'ai fait et je
devais pas faire l'armée je le dis dans
le liv j'ai failli
réformé alors que tout le monde voulait
être réformé Mo j'ai d non me réforme
pas faut que je fasse l'armée c'est
toute une histoire de dingue aussi ça et
donc quand je passe V juge hop là je
suis sur l'armée donc il me dit bah
après vous passez majeur bonne chance et
l'armée ça pas duré je me suis fait vir
aussi et hop et et donc 18 ans et demi
là je passe chez les majeurs et là ça va
pas loupé bam prison net donc là je fais
je fais une un premier séjour de 4 mois
je ressors et puis comme le juge
Bertrand l'avait dit quoi c'est je
ressors pire quoi je ressors oui parce
que tu tombes dans un banditisme plus
grand plus construit c'est à cette
époque là où tu commences à vider des
magasins en entier on avait déjà
commencé les magasins de luxe les
bureaux de tabac tout en entier on les
on on neutralisait les alarmes on vidait
les magasins je rentrais dans les
grandes surfaces moyennes surface je me
cachais dans les toilettes je sortais je
rentrais dans la là où il y a où la le
coffre fort où il y a le coffre fort je
me cachais dans un placard comme ça cl
j'avais le culot de me cacher dans un
placard et heureusement j'avais j'avais
tellement l'habitude de le faire que je
savais tout sur le bout des doigts des
gens rentrai dans le bureau faisaient
leur vie ils repartaient je sortais du
placard j'ouvrais la je cherchais la clé
du coffre dans les tiroirs tout ça je
trouve la clé du coffre je me recache
dans le placard je ressors j'ouvre le
coffre je remets la clé où je l'ai
trouvé je me recache dans le placard là
je ressors et là j'ouvrais et là tuouvre
le coffre fort tu as tous les billets tu
cl tu prends tu j'en mettais partout sur
moi de la claque je refermais le coffre
avec ma ma manchein sais pour pas les
emprintes clac clac tac je me mets dans
mon placard et j'attends je sors je me
recache dans les toilettes je me je
ressors dans dans dans le magasin et je
pars en pleine journée tu repars et
personne n' compris qui s'était fait
braquer j véridique à 100000 % je ne
mens pas je viv on vivait ça et donc
c'est là quand je dis le culot
l'intelligence et le talent dans le
mauvais côté de la barrière je donne des
exemples pour dire mettez votre culot
votre intelligence et votre talent dans
l'honnêteté vous déchirez tout notre
point de départ c'était ce premier
séjour en prison où tu dis effectivement
le juge avait raison en 4 mois tu
ressors déjà différ
après il y a eu les banques parce que la
celle de la Société Générale c'était
quoi ton rôle là-dedans j'avais commencé
déjà je savais déjà un peu à neutraliser
les systèmes d'alarmes et tout mais en
prison je fais une rencontre un un gars
qui qui était poseur d'alarme donc et
moi je disais toujours ce que l'être
humain a fait l'être humain peut le
défaire et donc la boben il est là donc
je lui dis il m'explique et tout ça donc
donc je sors de prison encore plus
expérimenté et de la délinquance on on
passe au banditisme et donc moi je suis
rentré je faisais les les magasins de
luxe en neutralisant les alarmes je sors
je dis à mes potes on va s'attaquer aux
banqu les banques et je neutralise mon
premier système d'alarme de banque on on
cambriole cette banque on passe tout le
weekend dans la banque à exploser le
coffre fort on prend une belle somme et
là je leur montre que c'est possible et
encore une fois en voulant je sais que
les gens vont dire il se fait la
Parbelle mais c'est vraiment vrai
j'avais j'ai commencé dans ma jeunesse
les les cambriolages de mais n
d'appartement très vite j'ai arrêté ça
en disant ça pourraitre c'est des gens
de monsieur madame tout le monde des
gens qui travaillent qui montent leur
boutique qui qui qui qui voilà qui
bossse et tu leur fais du mal même si on
va dire les assurances et tout ça mais
quand même c'est quand même c'est dur et
je dis non je me disait on va s'attaquer
les banques l'état on s'attaque aux
banques on fait les banques je leur
monre tout ça on fait plusieurs banques
mais là je suis pareil ça va pas je dis
non non on se trompe on se trompe et
quand j'essaie de de de de l'expliquer à
mes potes ils se disent David il a
changé David il a pété les plombs il a
ça lui va jamais enfin j'essaie
d'expliquer mais j'ai pas les mots c'est
compliqué ce que je ressens et donc et
et là ils me disent ils me font
comprendre non d' tu peux pas nous
laisser tomber et tout et tout je leur
dit on va en faire une dernière mais une
grosse si cette dernière est réussie on
sera tous gavés même ceux qui sont en
prison tout le monde sera gavé et parce
que tu prenais en plus soin des
personnes qui étaient restés en prison
ah oui on pay les avocats les mandats
les familles on est des je dis dis
c'était on avait vraiment on était une
équipe de on prenait soin de tout le
monde c'était la règle c'était notre
règle notre code d'honneur et donc je
prépare l'attaque du siège social de la
Société Générale à cand dans le Calvados
par les par les égous alors pourquoi les
égous on était tellement devenu très
connu dès que les policiers nous
voyaient ils nous contrôlaient et j'ai
dit à mes potes au moins sous terre on
peut se promener dans les égouts dans
toutes les canalisations les flics nous
ils savent pas avec des bateaux et tout
he détenu de plongé tout ça on était
vraiment fracassé hein je je donne juste
un exemple une fois vers la préfecture
de camp on on on on cherchait dans dans
dans les canalisations on rentrait dans
les canalisations de plus en plus
petites et j'avais mon pote devant moi
le bateau était amarré on rampait on
rampait avec des avec les les lumières
on rampait ah j'ai dis vas-y vas-y moi
j'étais tellement fou il me dit mais on
peut plus avancer je dis vas-y et d'un
coup il tour il me dit mais tu comprends
pas que on est c'est trop petit et il se
tourne vers moi comme ça et j'avais une
grosse grappe je le savais pas moi
j'avais une grosse grappe d'araignée il
met des grosses araignées audessus de la
tête et il me regarde comme ça avec sa
lampe comme ça il voit lui et il me dit
ah ah je dis quoi quoi et on criait il
dit tu as une araigné tu as les
araignées dit mais pourquoi tu me le dis
il me le dis pas et en fait on était
dans le trottoir de la préfecture et tu
avais le gardien de la préfecture qui
était en fond et quandendait des cris
dans le trottoir le mec il a dû se dire
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette bande
de taré donc on est sorti de là mais
entre autres he je pourrais passer ma
journée en raconter tellement j'en ai à
raconter c'est et donc là on s'est
attaqué à cette Société générale on a on
a trouvé la bonne canalisation et
pendant 4 mois on a creusé ce ce tunnel
dans les égout jusqu'à la banque pendant
4 mois alors là aussi c'est non mais toi
tu dis ça comme si c'était un mardi
matin mais tu es dans les égoutût tu tu
tu trouves l'endroit le plus direct et
tu te dis on va creuser un tunnel on va
mettre des ét on ah oua ouais un
chantier on a fait vraiment quand quand
on trouve la bonne canalisation déjà le
plus proche de la banque c'était il y
avait un il y avait un tube tu sais
c'est des tubes en béton comme ça en
rond qui sont superposés comme ça tu
vois fallait qu'on qu'on qu'on perce ce
tube et j'ai dit mes potes on va percer
là on va faire ça dimanche après-midi
habillé en travailleur quique de
chantier tenu de chantier tout ça on a
pris une Clio blanche avec gérophard
Orange on s'est garé devant la banque on
a mis les plots autour de ce ce truc il
est descendu on avait pris des des
lapidaaires à découper les routes à
essence tu sais essence pour découper
les routes le béton des routes là et il
fallait qu'il fasse une cisaille comme
ça une cisaille comme ça mais pour faire
ce truc il descend il
attaque mais un bruit de de malade
mental une fumée comme si ça sortait
d'une cheminée comme ça à un moment il
s'arrête il me dit V je dis quoi il me
dit ça fait pas trop de fumée je dis
rien ça se voit
pas si j'avais filmé c'était une PO je
dis t'inquiète rien ça impeccable il me
dit toi je dis tout va bien le but c'est
tout le temps les laisser zen tu vois et
il continue et d'un coup dans
l'oreillette j'entends patrouille de
flic patrouille je dirais chacun son
poste je le dis pas à l'autre je dis
chacun son poste restons tranquille
restons tranquille hop on là je fais
mine et pu je les revois les flic ils
arrivent au feu rouge comme ça ils nous
ont regardé moi j'étais là je faisais m
dé crrire ça ils ont démarré tranquille
ils sont partis ils étaient inta
tellement visible que ça pouvait pas
être quelque chose d'illégal pour
c'était pour eux c'était c'était ça
voilà et on a fait cette découpe et là
on avait la terre et on était à 5 m de
la salle des coffres en allant tout
droit et pendant 4 mois alors là on a
mon pote pareil il a fait des étés des
des étés avec des planches on avait tout
tout et on creusait on creusait on se
rel tout le temps soit lui soit un autre
avec les gateteurs et tout ça on s'est
fait une pièce on était au mur de la
banque on était au mur de la banque j'ai
fait un grand carré comme ça cl et juste
au-dessus tu avais les les trappes
d'aération ouais on voyait tous les
coffres clients tous les coffres de la
banque et tout ça c'était la salle des
coffres quoi on était là on était arrivé
j'ai fait un trait comme ça hop et là on
était ché tout le matos et tout et pour
pour attaquer le mur ah c'est c'est
cétait c'est un film CIT c'est un film
c'est un film qui a pas la fin heureuse
tout de suite parce que ça va a t'emmené
en prison de nouveau benah il y a eu un
film sur les égouts du Paradis moi j'ai
j'ai dit nous c'était les égouts de
l'enfer parce que on fait une petite
erreur dès le départ que j'ai pas
raconté volontairement parce queelle est
c'est le clou du spectacle dans le
spectacle elle est elle a sa grande
importance cette erreur on devait
arriver le 24 décembre 24 décembre 1998
ça tomba un jeudi ou un vendredi je sais
plus mais ça faisait un long weekend de
Noël et donc on est le 22 décembre on
attaque pour le mur on défonçait le mur
là et d'un coup j'entends les gateurs
qui disent attention voit voure bizarre
stoppz tout on stoppe tout et il y a une
voiture de de surveillance d'alarme qui
vient qui se garde derriè la banque qui
fait le tour de la banque le mec il est
au-dessus de nous il dit il est
auudessus j'entends mon oreillette on me
dit il est juste au-dessus de vous
faites pas de bruit et le mec il est
au-dessus de nous comme ça il refait le
tour et il repart il monte dans sa
voiture il s'en va on se réunit on dit
qu'est-ce que c'est on sait pas rien on
continue deuxème soir pareil là c'est
bizarre 3e soir ça se passe bien 4e soir
ça se passe bien et là
on on sort moi je dis faut faut ramener
tout le reste du matériel on est on est
là on est à ses Fame 2 jours de Noël il
faut ramener tout le matériel je sors
j'ai je rejoins une voiture avec avec un
pote à moi et là moi à cette voiture là
je me fais attraper GG cagou les mecs
cagoué tout il nous il nous sert to cl
et on arrive au commissariat et là je me
rends compte que l'erreur qu'on a fait
au départ a fait qu'ils ont es en train
de payer voilà je le paye et donc là je
je suis en garde à vue et là tout de
suite en garde à vue c'est évasion faut
que je me barre je je me suis toujours
dit une évasion tu l'as fait avant
d'aller en quand tu pars pour une grosse
peine fais ton évasion avant d'aller en
prison au bout d'une journée de garde à
vue les policiers viennent me chercher
et dans la voiture il me disent oh tu es
le nouveau spadar C on a fait le 20H ça
fait les journaux la des journau tu sais
que tu es nouveau spadar de c tout ça
non et il y a un policier en rigolant il
dit tu sais tu as plus qu'à faire comme
spadjari il a mis 4 mois pour s'évader 5
minutes plus tard j'étais évadé et là
c'est une évasion que je raconte dans
mon spectacle je m'évade sans armes sans
violence je les ai ramené dans un
anenton noir je les ai mis dans un truc
et je m'évade et là je fais un an de
cavale et là si je me mettais à raconter
l'année de Caval c'est pareil c'est un
film c'est un film je juste vite fait
comme ça un an de cavale je retrouve ma
femme en cavale mais
un mois plus tard mais déjà le premier
mois de cavale je m'évade le 24 décembre
1998 la veille de Noël c'est la veille
de Noël j'arrive à m'évader j'arrive à
atteindre le sud de la France et ensuite
je je manque de mourir dans les
montagnes en Italie dans les montagnes
entre l'Italie et la France euh je suis
recueilli par un italien il veut me
garder comme les Compagnons de la liber
de travail c'est les compagnons ils
apprennent des métiers tout ça dans les
les Compagnon du Devoir compagnon et
donc voilà et il me dit son pote il
vient il dit ou il dit par contre faut
qu'il aille se déclarer au carabinier
donc là je me sauve je pars et j'atteins
la ville de Gap et à Gap je me je
reconstitue un gang à Gap et l'idée
c'est de refaire des banques à Gap mon
frère amène de l'argent on achète une
voiture on loue une maison et là truc de
fou on va faire les courses on va faire
les courses on a de l'argent on est on a
ce qu'il faut en tune on a la voiture on
a la maison j'achète des oreillers des
couettes parce que ça est me plaisait
pas les couettes qui étaaient là-bas
j'achète de la je remplis le fricot les
placards on est dans l'obtique de
pouvoir de vouloir faire les banques et
le gars quand on achète la voiture
c'était en dépôt vente et il me dit par
contre n'hésite pas à changer les
bougies parce qu'elle est resté
longtemps là elle démarre bien et tout
mais il suffit qu'il des fois le matin
ou quoi met des bougies neu ça me je
prends les bougies et là l'insttin je
mets les bougies dans dans ma poche
comme ça je l'aiimis par habitude hop on
arrive à la caisse je paye je paye je
paye je paye bougie le mec la réflexion
à la vidéo truc de malade je je paye
tout et le le S vient voir il me dit
vous voulez monsieur monsieur je dis
quoi il me dit dans votre poche arrière
je dis les bougies je dis ouais non
désolé elle dit ah venez il dit de toute
façon c'est trop tard j'ai appelé les
flics je vous trouvé louche depuis dé
j'arrive je suis pour vol de bougie dans
les bureaux les flics viennent mes potes
me voient me faire emmener par les flics
menotte hop je monte dans la voiture he
vole de bougie vole à l'étalage de
bougie tu alors que je suis recherché à
quand j'arrive au commissariat c'est
trop loin à raconter le le la face que
je leur fais au commissariat de Gap il
s'en rappelle encore j'arrive à me
rebarer du commissariat de Gap sous un
faux nom sous un faux nom ils savent pas
que je suis David Desclos j'atteint
grenob mon frère j'appelle mon frère mes
potes ils disent ils sont tous atteint
Paris il dis David il s'est fait serrer
et tout il j'appelle mon frère on avait
des codes on avait des codes de dingue
des codes mais les codes de
fou en sécurité voilà tu j'en ai des
codes et tout ça mon frère revient à
agrenhom me donner de l'argent et tout
ça enfin et ça donc je pourrais passer
mon ma soir à te raconter tout ce qui
m'est arrivé pendant cette cavale où je
me refais sousi en Bretagne où je me
rebarre en bretag tout le long de cette
cavale où je je vis une vie de dingue et
que je suis avec ma femme aussi je me
rends compte je suis là je me dis un
jour ou l'autre ils finiront par m'avoir
c'est sûr à moins que je parte au Brésil
mais j'en suis pas là je suis pas et tu
as conscience de ça que ça peut pas être
infiniment de ton côé voilà ça fait un
an est passé plus d'un an euh un peu
plus d'un an est passé et je me dis j'ai
un truc à faire et c'est là maintenant
je j'en parle comme une espèce de
mission mais j'ai pas le mot dessus mais
je sais j'ai un truc à faire et je suis
pas à ma place il faut il faut que je me
rende il faut que je paye cette dette et
là le le 27 janvier 2000 c'est l'heure
du jugement je dis allez je me rends en
plein tribunal en pleine audience là ça
fait un tabac de fou parce que ils s'y
attendent pas le procureur qui a préparé
son son réquisitoire en disant Dav
Desclos irrécupérable en Caval sûrement
en train de faire des conneries tout ça
et moi quand je me rends ils on rienn
vient pas ils sont là ils sont choqués
j'explique que j'ai pas commis de
violence même en mes vadents parce
qu'ils veulent me mettre une violence en
disant que j'ai poussé les filles je
j'essaie de prouver parap B que j'ai pas
comm de violence et c'est vrai je leur
fait un tour de passe pass je leur
explique qu'on a on a creusé un tunnel
sans armes et sans violence demander 7
ans pour avoir creuser un tunnel alors
qu'il y a des violeurs qui prennent 5
ans dont trois de surcis je leur dis je
leur dis vous vous rendez pas compte ils
mettent quand même au début 5 ans mais
en appel aussitôt le pro qui fait appel
par qu' mettre 5 ans pour le tunnel et 6
mois pour l'évasion je m'en sort
sait pas demop non plus mais là en app
cétait trop en appelle ils ont dit non
c'est ils ont vu que et puis je suis
passé devant une juge qui me connaissait
depuis tout gamin qui qui qui rêvait de
m'avoir qui qui à juste titre avait
laarchee contre moi parce que je j'ai
joué avec elle depuis trop longtemps et
puis là savait pas que pour une fois je
je ne mentais pas pour une fois je je
j'expliquais que j'avais vraiment
quelque quelque chose et là m'a mis 7
ans pour le tunnel 1 an pour l'évasion
du surcis qui est tombé des peines et T
monté à 12 ans et demi c'était ouais 12
ans et demi et j'ai eu des grâces
confusion de peine des confusions de
peine des grâces et tout c'est
redescendu à 8 ans et 4 mois 8 ans et 4
mois et sur 8 ans et 4 mois j'ai fait 5
ans plein ok mais pour pendant ces 5 ans
j'ai ma femme qui m'a attendu pendant 5
ans qui venait me voir à tous les
parloirs j'ai j'ai écrit j'ai bah déjà
tu as commencé le promenade Comedy Club
c'est là que à peine arrivé en promenade
les mecs il me disent il voulait que je
raconte mon évasion que je raconte ma
cavale je les faisais rire j'animais la
promenade et quand souvent l'ouvre fin
de promenade ils étaient dans l'histoire
David tu tu descends demain tu racontes
la suite et il faisait le mot la
promenade se remplissait tout le monde
venait écouter ils ont mis la promenade
du coméy club et là je me suis dit il y
a quelque chose à faire avec ça il y a
quelque chose à faire et et surtout je
les voyais m'écouter comme un héros
j'avais envie de leur dire parce que moi
j'avais mis 20 ans à comprendre ça c non
non fantasme pas oui leur dire que
derrière c'est des années de vie de
gaché c'est du gâi comme j'arrête pas de
le dire que c'est du gâachi des morts
des tout mais comment leur dire alors
qu'ils sont en train de rigoler que je
les fais rire qu'ils me prennent pour un
héros si je commence à leur faire la
morale ils vont me dire David tu es plus
marrant dégage je le sais parce que j'ai
été comme eux c'est ce que je leur
aurais dit si quelqu'un quand un grand
nous faisait rire nous raconta ses
histoires si le grand commençait à nous
faire la morale c'est bon on va faire je
le sais donc je me dis comment trouver
la méthode pour leur parler en leur
envoyant des messages tout en les
faisant rire quand même et c'est là que
j'ai l'idée du spectacle écro et de rire
où j'écris les prémises du spectacle et
tout et je le teste en promenade où je
j'arrive avec l'ancien David descl où je
fais rire je fais rire et petit à petit
bascule avec des messages tout en
continuant à faire rire tout en les
messages subtils comme ça clac clac clac
clac et à la fin on fait des débats et
tu as des Gunes qui vienent devir en
disant tu étais sérieux David quand tu
me disais ça je dis bah ouais et je vois
que les débats s'installent et là ils me
disent mais ouais et je vois les mecs
qui sortent et au bout de 6 mois ils
m'ont envoie des cartes postèes en me
disent merci David de m' fait comprendre
je travaille j'ai une femme j'ai suivi
tes conseils et je me dis si ça marche
pour eux qui sont qui étaient en prison
il faut le faire dès dehors mais c'est
là que j'ai l'idée d'écrire j'écris je
teste dans les promenades j'écris je je
fais je et je sors au bout de 5 ans ma
femme qui m'a attendu pendant 5 ans je
sors avec ce spectacle sous le bras et
là je dis je vais tout défoncer je vais
à Paris je fais les scènes ouvertes je
fais les premières scènes ouvertes le
chanchman Comedy Club et tout je fais
des scènes ouvertes ça commence à
marcher et tout ça mais là au bout de 1
an et demi j'ai mes potes qui vientent
de me voir et bon bah David tu t'es bien
reposé il dit tu on fait quoi maintenant
je dis les gars vous avez pas compris
moi je me suis rendu j'ai d'autres idées
j'ai mais David tu peux pas nous faire
ça il y en a encore qui sont en prison
ceux qui t'ont aidé quand toi tu y étais
tu peux pas tu peux pas nous laisser
tomber c'est pas possible nous c'est à
la vie à la mort rappelle-toi on se l'
dit c'est à la vie à la mort je dis ouis
mais les gars on va faire autrement on
va se lancer dans les spectacles on va
on va dans le théâtre dans le cinéma
tout ce qu'on faisait comme ça on va le
faire dans le cinéma on va gagner et là
je me rends compte que ton monte et tout
moi je suis quelqu'un qui me laisse pas
faire eux non
plus voilà c'est des amis d'enfance je
va pas me retrouver en guerre avec des
parce que ils comprennent pas mon point
de vue et et alors à ce moment-là qui
sait si j'ai raison tort ou pas tu et
donc là je me dis NON je vais il faut y
retourner et là il faut payer la dette
et tout on est j'ai une discussion
franche avec eux je dis à combien vous
estimez mon départ ah oui tu tu tu poses
déjà une condition de ok je reviens mais
on sait ensemble quand est-ce que je
peux arrêter par voilà on sait on sait
la somme pour aider un tel un tel un tel
qui sont en prison un tel qui on on voit
à peu près donc c'est une gre somme mais
moi là je suis au SMIG je suis au SM et
je gagne pas grand-chose je su j'ai ma
femme j'ai ma fille qui vient de naître
et tout ça je suis là soit je je les
écoute et ça soit je les écoute pas on
part en guerre donc qui que je suis dans
un cul de sac on a toujours fait le
hachich et donc là on avait nos
connexions on était la PL on a notre
tour le ce fameux 43 où tu trouvais de
tout là-bas j'ai mis en place des go
fast pour amener du du hachiche et j'en
suis pas fier j'essaie juste de donner
une explication on a commencé à faire
les premiers goofhas qui marchaient et
j'ai commencé à à dire bahah un tel qui
était pas bien tac et on lui donne ça un
tel tac on commence à donner à
dispatcher à pouvoir régler ma dette et
on tombe dans la pénurie alors qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'une pénurie c'est quand tu
trouves plus un gram de hachiche en
France tu trouves personne peut trouver
du hachiche pourquoi parce que soit ça
c'est
bloqué les frontières marocaines ou
espagnoles ou hollandais sont et donc
j'arrive à me remettre en connexion avec
un un pote en Espagne qui lui arrive ça
la pénurie commence à se déconter un peu
mais lui il arrive en Espagne à avoir en
grosse grosse quantité et je descends en
Espagne on fait d'abord un premier gas
qui marche bien le deuxième je descends
en avion et je j'y vais pour ramener 300
kg de seme les voitures gofas qui
viennent qui viennent c'est une voitures
volé en gofas qui viennent à l'allée se
font péter à Bordeaux ok ils se font
attraper à Bordeaux et donc j'ai la
nouvelle on me disa les voitures se sont
fait péter à Bordeaux on t'en renvoie
d'autres mais ça va mettre au moins une
semaine moi j'avais donneré ma parole à
un de ceux que qui était dans la galère
là il était grave il s'était mis en
dette avec une grosse équipe et si je
ramenais pas un minimum pour calmer son
il ça pouvait tourner en règlement de
compte et donc l'autre il me dit je dis
non je peux pas attendre je voilà et je
vais dans une grande surface je remplis
j'achète une valise et je vais dans le
hangar avec mon ce ce ce ce gros ce pote
là et je lu dis rempl la valise il me
dit qu'est-ce que tu vas faire il dit
attends une semaine les voitures exar je
dis non rempl la valise il dit mais tu
tu es ouf et je dis il remplit la valise
25 kg de seum c'est comme si tu ramenais
100 kg de bon quoi c'était c'était
qualité et en plus en pleine pénurie en
pleine pénuriie où tu as rien donc tu
étais tu rentrais 5 kg de seum c'est
comme si tu tu étais le roi du pétrole
quoi j'arrive euh et je leur dis
maintenant amenez-moi à la gare mais il
dis tu pourras pas passer il y a eu les
attentat en Espagne à cette époque là il
y a eu des gros attentats dans les gares
je sais pas si tu te souviens et ils
avaient mis les portiques comme dans les
avions ça fait que tous les voyageurs
qui passaient fallait qu'il passe sous
la sous le portique et je dis
ramenez-moi à la gare me disent mais tu
un arvallo tu tu tu ils ont mis des
portiques tu passeras pas je dis
ramenez-moi la gare je sais ce que je
fais les gars et je traverse vers la
gare et je vois effectivement les
porties tu peux pas passer ils sont tous
là ils scannent tout et tout je fais
tout le tour de la moi je cette histoire
là à chaque fois que je raconte je dis
c'est le Fernandel la vache et le
prisonnier c'est vraiment un truc de fou
je fais tout le tour avec ma grosse
valise j'arrive à passer alors c'est des
grillages je plie un grillage comme ça
les 25 kg j'arrive c'est dur elle est
lourde la valise je la passe par-dessus
comme ça fort je la jette en pliant le
grillage comme ça au maximum je la elle
passe par-dessus je passe par-dessus CLA
cl j'arrive par je longe les les voies
les voix j'arrive par derrière la gare
j'arrive à rentrer jolou il y avait des
poteaux je mets derrière le poteau je
contour les poteau par qu'il y a des des
gens qui passent des gardiens hop et
j'arrive à rentrer dans la gare et je
suis dans la gare avec tout le monde et
je vois le train qui part pour la France
j'arrive à monter dans le train on
arrive à la gare de serbert serber en
France frontière espagnole il y a un
petit bureau de tabac il y a un petit
tabac avec il lou des chambres au dessus
me rappellerai toujours et il y a
quelques trains qui part un train qui
part pour Montpellier un train qui qui
part pour Narbonne et un train qui va
partir de nuit pour Paris et là jeouis
le train qui part pour je crois que
c'est Montpellier ou Narbon je me
rappelle plus et je d je vais prendre
celui-là et de là je vais je crois que
c'est Montpellier de Montpellier je
prendre un train il y aura plus de
trains qui vont à Paris je monte dans ce
train là il y a personne c'est un petit
train je suis dans le train juste un
monsieur en face de moi je mets la
valise dans les partiment je suis là
comme ça j'attends d'un coup j'entends
du bruit je regarde la Douine volante
qui monte liseré rouge sur le pantalon
dès que je vois la doine volante liser
rouge sur le pantalon che il s'en fout
des papiers il il fouillent il cherchent
que la drogue et tout ça jeir je dis
merde il fouilleent ils fouilleent il
fouille ils ouvrent la valise ça qui
cette valise je sais pas je dis il y
avait un gars sur le quai là qui qui qui
traînait là je à mon avis c'est à lui
tout ça il sert la main du mec c'est un
policier en civil moi il prenne il
prennent mes papiers déclos David
pédigret monsieur vous allez nous suivre
il dis et vous avez intéresst ce qu'on
retrouve le mec he que vous dites sur le
K et tout ça moi je dis moi je déécris
le mec et tout ça t ta t je dis vont
jamais le retrouver oh moi je dis le mec
le PO en CIV dit non je l'ai pas vu avec
une valise personne m'a vu avec la
valise il y a pas de caméra dans la dans
la garde de serber pas de caméra quelle
chance je me tape 96 he de garde à vue
mais les premiersr les premiers 24
heures je suis là je ni je n en bloc
c'est pas moi moi je suis là ma marque
de Fring que j'ai créé avec mon pote
tout ça je su j'avais rendez-vous dans
les magasins cartelingl en Espagne tout
ça j'ai tout tout ça c'était préparé
j'avais tous les les trucs ils font ils
font ils se rendent compte que c'est
vrai 24 he de garde à vue 48 he de garde
à vue 48h m David viens c'est bon on l'a
le mec à l'Audi c'est bon viens
confrontation oh j'arrive en
confrontation devant le mec le mec il
pleurait il me dis David attends son ta
dépos son à son importance si tu nous
dis que c'est lui le mec àodi que tu
l'as vu avec la valise il part ballon je
pouvais pas faire ça et impossible
impossible de faire ça c'est dans nos
codes dans nos trucs je pouvais pas et
là dans ma dépage je dis non je serai un
menteur de dire que ce monsieur avait la
valise c'est pas lui non je tu crémine
pas mais tu
le je le charge pas je dis non non ce
n'est pas lui ce n'est pas lui je le
sors même carrément je dis non il y a à
aucun moment je l'ai vu avec cette
valise tout ça et là ça fait déjà 48
heur que je suis en garde à vue j'ai ma
femme ma fille qui m'attend et tout je
n'importe qui aurait pu essayer de le
charger et tout il relâche moi
prolongation de garde vue je fais 96 he
de garde à vue je suis défér au parquet
déféré au parquet hop monsieur déclot
tout ça ouais ok vous avez les
cartelingla tout mon plan était là mais
cette valise Monsieur déclot Tout P
qu'on s pas mon a de dépôt mon de dépôt
je suis en mon de dépôt à perpignon et
là c'est c'est un film c'est c'est c'est
même un bout d'écouer de rire 2 de mon
spectacle 2 parce que tous les 4 mois
tous les 4 mois je passe devant le juge
alors quand je fais dans dans écr rire 2
je suis pressé de de faire ce passage là
dans éc rire 2 parce que je le dis en
rigolant mais ce que j'ai vécu c'est
énorme parce que tous les 4 mois je
passe pour renouvellement de mandat de
dépôt je passe devant le juge des
renouvellements le juge me dit Monsieur
déclos il y a pas assez d'éléments pour
moi je vouslais vous avez une femme une
fille tout ça n je vous laisse sortir en
provisoire mais le procureur a 10 jours
pour faire appel 9e jour et demi c'est
10 jours à Minuit he 23h40 23h40 la
porte qui s'ouvre claque claac déclos
Greff j'arrive au greffe le procureur a
fait appel vous passez dans quelques
jours à ex en Provence je pars aveex en
Provence le procureur appelle en appelle
il me confirme le mandat de dépôt
confirmation du mandat de dépôt retour à
la maison d'arrêt je refais 4 mois 16
mois 20 mois
23h
23h55 clac claac
déclos GREF le procureur ne fait pas
appel vous êtes sorti mais nous sommes à
dragillan j'avais été transfert à
dragillan entre temps nous sommes à
Draguignan il y a aucun bus aucun taxi
il y a rien rien rien il est minuit vaut
mieux que vous restiez une nuit de plus
ici pour prendre quelque chose demain
matin mais vous êtes obligé de nous
faire une décharge ouais comme quoi vous
restez commeoi de vous-même parce que si
vous arrivez quelque chose dans la nuit
c'est je dis je ne signe rien du tout je
sors tout de suite je suis sorti en
pleine nuit j'ai marché sur l'autoroute
sur la sur la route et après sur
l'autoroute j'ai un P j'ai pris une dame
qui m' prend en stop et tout et j'ai
atteint j'ai atteint quand je suis
arrivé à qu j'ai vu ma femme ma fille
j'étais voir mes comp mes anciens
complices j'étais voir il m'ont dit
David tu es un bonhomme tu es un homme
tu es un homme je dis j'ai qu'une
question est-ce que je vous dois encore
quelque chose tu nous dois plus rien
c'est nous qui devons je dis vous ne
devez plus rien je ne vous dois plus
rien on se doit plus rien mais je veux
l'entendre de votre bouche vous non tu
es un homme tu nous dois plus rien je
dis mainten non ce qui est en bon terme
bonne chance à vous j'étais sorti en
provisoire je fais à peine une petite
année en provisoire je passe en tribunal
dans le sud de la France je passe et là
je passe à Toulon à Toulon le proc
demande c'est enferme j'avais fait que
20 20 mois et là pareil le proc mais il
me met C en ferme mais j'avais prévu
avec un pote et tout j'avais tout prévu
et là je je me rebarre je m'évade donc
là je pars 4 ans et demi de Caval 4 ans
et demi Caval où je fais ambulancier
attaché au SAMU de Paris je fais des
SAMU dans tout Paris avec un fauxom du
coup sous un faux nom par que ça ça
alors on va pas tout vous raconter mais
vraiment intéressez-vous au travail de
de David mais mais il y a cette période
là où il va travailler alors qu'il est
en Caval ça c'est fou aussi et je
travaille au SAMU ambulancier attaché au
SAMU de Paris et le soir je suis sur
scène je fais des spectacle sur scène
sous le nom de pinlu l'envers de Lupin
je je vous mon des des des des sketchs
de 5 minutes hein c'est les scènes
ouvertes a avec voilà le com cl compag
tout ça tous les gars tous m potes que
j'ai rencontré qui fais leur début qui
sont maintenant très connus ouais je
pense àidia je pense àil pas tous les
citer Alban Ivanov tout ça enfin t tous
les tous les mecs Verino Verino j'en ai
connu plein et au bout de 4 ans et demi
il me rattrape ils font une enquête
comme quoi et ils se rendent compte que
c'est vrai que j'ai travaillé au SAMU de
Paris et que je montais sur scène et
tout ça tout en étant en cavale et que
mes deux fils sont nés pendant un j'ai
trois enfants une femme et trois enfants
et la juge a ce mot magique elle me dit
elle dit c'est dé clos j'ai jamais vu un
dossier comme ça vous vous êtes un
symbole de réinsertion me dit je vous
laiss ça tu t'es auto réinséré en Caval
et il me dit elle me dit je vous laisse
sortir avec le bracelet électronique le
bracelet électronique et après en
conditionnel elle me dit vous allez
faire quelque chose de bien de votre vie
et cette juge elle est magique
magnifique et et j' puis ben après
longue histoire je rencontre stommy Bugy
je rencontre Stomy Bugy je rencontre
Véronique Guimard le théâtre du Gymnase
le Jamel Comedy Club ça marche ça
fonctionne je monte une pièce avec Tommy
Bugy un jour j'ai des3 avec Cyril gel et
Dominique cou et on on amène tout ça mon
spectacle mon livre qui sort aux
éditions flamarion au même moment le
spectacle écrou et deire commence à bien
péter mon livre aux éditions flamarion
et je me dis ça y est enfin parce que
c'est des années de galère ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure quand on c'est des
années des années de où je joue dans
devant devant CIN personnes quatre
personnes où je galère comme un dingue
avant de rencontrer tout ce beau monde
et d'un coup covid oui le covid noirsale
il faut qu'on qu'on arrive à clôturer
cette cette interview je crois qu'on
pourrait écouter pas mal d'heur juste
pour pour terminer déjà merci pour ta
générosité mais surtout je veux rappeler
que au-delà de tout ça tu joues aussi
ton spectacle dans des salles mais tu
vas jouer dans dans des prisons pour
pour pour essayer de véhiculer ses
messages je je dis en vrue parce que là
c'est c'est c'est plus moi qui te
remercie de faire tout ça tu fais des
rencontres entre les victim et les
détenus ça ça je trouve ça incroyable on
a eu l'idée ave Tommy Bugy quand en
faisant le spectacle dans les prisons on
s'est dit il manque quelque chose et on
s'est dit et là on s'est dit la place
des victimes et on a rencontré Marie
Ange de la Rosa qui a été victime d'un
gros braquage qui on a proposé de venir
avec nous et là après le spectacle
pendant le débat mer de la Rosa monte
sur scène avec nous et échange avec les
détenus et là la victime qui explique
aux détenus les S qu' ce qu'elle a vécu
et tout ça c'est tout simplement magique
nous on appelle ça la justice
restaurative et on voilà on est en train
de l'étendre de plus en plus et et on on
déborde de pro là de plein de choses
avec avec toutes les toutes l'équipe
Stomy Passi Calbo Darc jeis pas tous les
cité hein mais euh c'est Salif Keet Mike
euh voilà on est on a voà on sait bien
s'entouré et encore merci aussi à toi et
toute ton équipe c'éit vraiment un grand
plaisir de beaucoup davci à to merci
merci beaucoup merci à David declo on a
eu beaucoup de chance qu'il soit si
généreux dans ses explications si vous
voulez la version un peu plus longue de
cette interview elle va sortir d'ici
quelques semaines sur le Podcast des
interviews à la table vous aurez un lien
dans la description avec un lien vers le
spectacle de David et un lien vers mon
premier jeu arnaque bluff et diamant qui
sort dans quelques jours c'est un jeu de
société de deux à quatre joueurs à très
bientôt Ciao